woman is facing social security fraud
charges told investigators she
dismembered her husband and threw away
his remains this is a story our i-team
is just breaking right now david charn
is here with those allegations david
according to these court documents this
woman kept receiving her husband's
social security
years after he died and when
investigators caught on they say they
found out a whole lot more
court documents show 69 year old nancy
schedleski dismembered her husband and
lived off his social security benefits
for four years investigators say the
social security administration was never
made aware of her husband's death and
paid more than 120 thousand dollars into
his account
but prosecutors say schedleski's husband
died in 2015. court documents say
chadleski admitted to dismembering his
body packaging the body parts and
throwing them out in the trash in their
former pennsylvania home
she told family he had died but there
was quote no ambulance no
hospitalization no funeral no burial and
no cremation investigators say she then
moved from pennsylvania to las vegas in
2017. and in late 2019 investigators
tried contacting shedleski's husband
several times and got no response
now right now shedleski is out on bond
it's important to tell you that she's
not charged with any crime that we know
of in connection to her husband's death
i did reach out to police in
pennsylvania about that today i also
reached out to her public defender and
i'm still waiting to hear her side of
this story kirsten